hey guys Pete here here into a top
moments video this week for Game of
Thrones season 7 episode 4 the spoils of
war it was a fantastic episode 5 4 is
the best episode of this season but
probably up there and best episodes of
the entire series in some ways there's
so many good episodes as well just make
that claim but anyways if you ever
watched it obviously there's a spoiler
warning here I'm going to do a quick top
moments and then I'll do a recap and
review deep dive in depth later on so
the first big moment for me was that we
saw that Jamie has some feelings about
what happened we see him looking at the
gold and paying off bran but
bran points it out and he says you know
what did the old lady do something you
know to pissed you off at the end of her
day but we know that this is him
thinking about the fact that Joffrey had
been poisoned it brought up that whole
idea and he knows that underneath it all
part of that is what drives Cersei
hatred for Tyrion although things don't
matter after all this is said done
anyways and besides he killed Tywin I
mean it's not like she's going to
forgive him either way the next big
thing for me was that she is in
negotiations to get herself some sell
swords again her motivation here may be
changed after she finds out what happens
at the field of fire but it's still very
interesting because her army got wiped
out but she does have a back-up plan the
next big moment is that brandi is not
brand
he's the three-eyed Raven and there's a
definite difference we see this in the
big moment when Littlefinger tries to
sort of get his favor by giving him the
blades of the Larian steel blade the
cat's paw blade that was used in an
attempt on his life this coupled with
mirrors big moment of leaving sets the
stage that we and understand that bran
is definitely not the same person
mirrors leaving did this in a very
bittersweet way we saw that all the
sacrifice and the people that had lost
their lives to get him to where he was
going Jojen
code or his direwolf summer none of it
really affects him and even though he's
just spent years with nira
her leaving doesn't really affect him
he's got other things on his mind so
yeah I mean it's kind of awesome that
mirrors leaving because that plateau and
read back into the picture but we're not
sure how that's going to go so this is
kind of heart-wrenching and let's hope
that we see some more mirror down the
road because it would suck if that was
her final purpose was just to show us
how much brand is not really brand
anymore
the next big moment was obviously re
arriving at Winterfell the guards not
believing her was pretty good they had
good reason not to believe her but she
has smarts the money and some people
were saying that they were disappointed
with the actual reunion I thought it was
pretty good
it shows the fact that they are happy to
be back together they are sad that Ned
is gone and the family's not the same
and Aria points it out this one's also
says that everyone that remembers what
Ned looks like is dead she points out
that they're still alive so even though
this wasn't like gushy and bubbling I
think that they connected in that way
and I think their relationship can
actually be a lot better moving on now
of course there's a little alarmed to
hear about Aria's listing it's just
clear that they don't know what each
other's been through yet or how much
each other's change next big moment was
obviously Brienne sparring with Aria all
those hard to tolerate training montages
relax peas and finally paid off I guess
we see that Aria is a true warrior
what's he's learned from Serio what
she's learned from the faceless men
she's able to best Brienne so that's
something as she points out herself that
she wants to train with Brienne because
Brienne bested the Hound so this is
pretty frigging impressive a good
showing fun to watch I know it got
leaked early and one of the previews
which is a shame because it would only
been better if it would have been a
total surprise that we didn't know
coming the next big moment here what for
me was definitely Littlefinger we see
that look in his face and we see the
showdown like the locking of eyes
between him and Arya he's struck he
shook it what he's seen I guess you
could say that his plan was to get in
with bran because he might be the
easiest one he found out that isn't
gonna happen and he sees that arya is a
real threat those are what she knows and
what she might know from being out in
the world but also her skills I mean
she's impressive all the way around and
he doesn't even know about I mean he may
know I was thinking after the fact he
may know about what happened with the
Freys and know that she's involved but
we don't really know if he knows that so
he's definitely shook which is good if
overall as far as I'm concerned the next
big moment was the carvings underneath
the cave Danny seeing that getting some
real evidence and the awe that she shows
whenever he mentioned the children of
the forest and everything I mean this
moment was not lost on her John was
smart to take her down there and show
her that in that way it gives the
connection to the Past in the history of
everything that is around them and you
can't just rush and say she can't just
pass that off she sees the importance
but of course she still insists on him
bending the knee he still makes his
point which is a hundred percent valid
and that's just the way this is going to
be at this point we find out when they
go back outside because she's hit with
the news that they did take Casterly
Rock but that it wasn't all that they
you know that they hope in that you're
on showed up and destroyed their fleet
that leads right into the next big
moment and that's Danny's dilemma she
doesn't know what to do her instinct is
to go and to burn the red key to the
ground which in retrospect isn't that
benefit idea
yeah she'll kill the guards there the
Kingsguard and the other people that are
close to Cersei but she would
necessarily have to destroy the whole
city right of course that wouldn't make
for a very good thing so we'll just I'll
just not go down that road right now but
he has a real dilemma she's losing she
tells them
she seems to have lost a little bit of
confidence in Tyrion although she may
rethink that after the fact because we
see how she acts but she has this weapon
of mass destruction she could just use
it any things now none of her advisors
want to see her do that so she turns the
John which is a big but turning point in
their relationship I would say and he
points out what they pointed out but
just with a different perspective look
you birthed these dragons you hatch them
something that Noah thought was possible
people believe in you they believe you
or you know you're able to do other
impossible things like bring about a
better world if you go in there and you
destroy King's Landing they'll realize
you're just like everybody else we don't
get to see where that goes because it
cuts away but we find out later what her
compromise actually is the next big
moment is probably dago's hitting on the
sandy because it's funny but something
more comes out of this sequence and I
think it is easy to overlook so I'm
going to point it out without saying it
Davos basically explains to Jon that him
getting with Daenerys is the fastest way
to get them to appoint the
reconciliation of their goal it's like I
said it's kind of subtle in there and
most fans don't like the idea because we
know that they're related but nobody
involved in this show understands that
at this point who's there
so even though he doesn't say hey look
why don't you marry this woman and then
we'll get this taken care of
he sort of points out that hey you know
I've seen this and John says all well
there's no there's no time for any of
that you know the White Walkers are
coming but probably later on they'll
realize that hey this will get everybody
on the same page if a marriage comes out
of this then we get Theon's return which
ended in way that a lot of people
predicted john wants to kill him but he
can't then we find out in the next big
moment that Daenerys isn't there and we
know where she is now the battle itself
is the biggest moment and there are a
ton of little moments inside this
first let's just talk about the all of
this thing it was fantastic to watch
first big moment of them coming over the
hill the storm behind them we hear them
before we see them and then she comes
out of the clouds just as jamie-san he
thinks they can hold them obviously they
can't now we see that first moment where
she burns the line and that is a great
way to set the tone of what's about to
happen here we see that this army
doesn't really stand a chance against
the fire and the riders get some great
shots of them burning you know coming
through the burning wall we see them
hopping up on the backs of their horses
and pull strides loose arrows I mean you
know this is really great action we find
out that they did in fact bring KY
Byrnes weapon and this was sort of the
best part of the battle for me was when
bran is going across he gets in a
showdown was the dothraki rider who
chops off the leg of his horse and then
when he sort of stumbling through the
fire and we see all these guys dying
burning to death I mean it was just a
really good battle scene like one we
haven't really seen and it was just
friggin awesome
now carrion shows up on the field for a
big moment he has a good vantage point
where he can see what's happening Ron
manages to loose a bolt that misses and
that puts Danny in a situation where she
will try to destroy it on the ride back
around brawn hit his mark and we see
drogon fall from his flight definitely a
tense moment there he able he's able to
turn it around though and he destroys
the weapon but bran gets out alive
drogon has to land because he's injured
Daenerys tries to remove the bolt Tyrion
watches in somewhat of horror as Jamie
notices her there and he realizes that
he's going to charge Jimmy does just
that for another big moment and just as
he's about to get burnt bran shows up
out of nowhere and not
into the water he's sort of thinking
there when the episode end so yeah
there's just a ton of stuff that
happened here short episode but
action-packed all the way from beginning
to end
very interesting that Cersei has plans
to get the golden company on the payroll
we did find out that the gold was sent
ahead so that's that part of the of
everything should be okay for them they
took a horrible loss on the battlefield
and when you think about it Daenerys
would have won this battle dragon or not
as of Dothraki tells Tyrion was there
watching them being slaughtered you know
because people didn't fight that well
they were outmatched all the way around
Daenerys used rogue on here as a show of
force but one of the biggest things that
you might not have noticed is that he
destroyed the food supply the gold made
it through so all she really did was
burn up most of the food that exists in
Westeros and winter is definitely here
so this may really come back to hurt her
later on the Starks are all back
together except for their bastard
brother John I like the way things are
moving at Winterfell at this point I'm
not totally in love with bran being less
than bran but I guess if you think about
it it was always set up this way I made
several videos about bran in the off
season and I pointed that out that his
purpose is much more than saying you
know warding a dragon or just giving
John the information about his parents
so this is just the way the show has
decided to handle it so I think it's
okay we see that Arya is definitely a
warrior to be taken 100% seriously and
as I mentioned this has nothing to do
with the fact that she can take faces as
well little fingers in a tough spot we
knew that was going to happen but now we
know what it looks like though the
interesting to see where he goes and
even though we expected that this was
really going to turn the tables
Cersei still in a pretty good position
in King's Landing Jon hasn't gotten what
he wants yet he's gotten the dragon
glass but he hasn't gotten the narrow
on his side and Danny definitely made a
you know a statement here but it hasn't
really improved her position that much
all it did was show that she can destroy
an army some people were you know
responding on Twitter that Jamie died
Jamie's not dead that landing theme was
just that you know I can't imagine in
any case that he would be dead here I
can't prove that he's alive because they
didn't show him in the trailer but I
would bet a lot of money that he is so I
wasn't worried about that if I were you
so yeah just an awesome episode make
sure you guys tell me what you think in
the comments make sure you like this
video if you enjoyed it as mentioned I
will be putting a full-length in-depth
breakdown of the episodes of team by
scene like I always do so make sure you
subscribe and make sure you turn on
notifications by clicking on that little
bell so that you know when my new videos
come out you can also follow me over on
Twitter and my other social media
accounts to see what I'm doing thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon
you
you